Certainly, looking at whether the sample means are higher or lower than the
population means provides some indication of whether or not the song may have
helped or hurt student engagement and learning. But this barely tells the whole
story. We could look at the difference between the population mean and sample
mean, but the population is based on thousands of scores, whereas the sample
mean is based off of just 20 scores. So this isn't an accurate comparison. We
also can't find the z score of a sample mean using the population standard
deviation sigma, because sigma is based on the variability of each individual
score, not the variability of a mean of scores. Therefore, the third option is
correct. Using the central limit theorem, we need to look at the distribution of
sample means for all samples of size 20, and then find where our two sample
means fall on these distributions.